[Music]
so just introduce ourselves my name is
David I'm actually a product manager at
Google I work primarily on service
management and SEO itseo obviously being
an open source service mesh project that
was originally sponsored by Google and
IBM but now there are a large number of
contributors from a various number of
companies and also joining me today is
Sandeep Sandeep works in devrel also
focusing on SEO service management he's
actually there really he's the Guru
around all things technical when it
comes to SEO so when you had any really
gnarly questions please feel free to
save them for him when he gets up here
so just to talk a little so just let's
cover what we're gonna talk about here
today we're gonna basically touch on
[Music]
managing services with the service mesh
there are some you know service mesh
actually gives you a bunch of different
capabilities we're also talk a little
bit about incorporating some of the SRA
best practices into that process and
actually what that looks like and we'll
go through will actually you have a
demonstration on how you'd step up step
that step up a or step through setting
up some practical examples of SLS or
service level objectives so this is sort
of what we're going to focus on today
but before we get started
and again it's a little bit difficult
for me to say how many people in this
room have actually used this do before
awesome hats or about it's hard to I can
see some hands over on the right hand
side I couldn't see anyone on the left
hand side actually to be honest not
because you didn't put your hands up
because the lights through my eyes how
many people actually have East um in
production okay awesome that's fantastic
I would actually love to you know maybe
afterwards we could catch up I'd love to
understand what you guys are doing with
this - yeah so let's talk a little bit
about let's kick things off with you
know what service service management
like in a micro service environment so
micro services you know a pretty awesome
they that the main objective about micro
services is the
increase developer velocity and
productivity so this is the key thing
what we what we hear all the time
consistently is I want a common
development pipeline that works for all
my environments but also want to be able
to get new capabilities into the hands
of my customers as soon as possible and
do that very very safely and really
reduce risk so there are a bunch of
things here that micro services allow
you to do that that that makes things
better the challenge of micro services
though is they increase complexity so
with that increased complexity you start
getting you know some additional things
you need to do in order to manage those
micro services so things like
orchestration becomes important
understanding how your services get
connected becomes important so we
actually need a high level of
abstraction this is where I again
kubernetes gets you part way there but
SEO or service mesh can actually help
there provides at a high level of
abstraction so let's look at a so I
actually have a really pretty basic
application here this is a demo app and
if I had a saw for developer you know
first join a development team and we're
looking at building an application or we
had an application already in production
I probably you know people get on a
white board and I'd start drawing stuff
out and you'd end up with you know a you
know slimmed down version of something
like this that talks about you know what
that application looks like and even in
this very very simple example we have
around 10 micro services which you may
be running many instances of from a
back-end perspective and in here we
actually have a bunch written in go some
written in Python a couple in one in
Java this actually gives you the ability
now to deploy certain services
independently of other I can scale for
example my front-end independently to
scaling my check out service I can patch
or release add service independently of
other services but I've also done
another thing I've actually created
complexity around managing all these
services and also managing the
communication paths between these
services
so look at you know if I look at the the
services themselves and actually
managing those I have to now secure the
communications between them I have to
protect services rate limits in place
and so that you know if I don't
necessarily want a service hitting
another service beyond its load capacity
so I can put rate limits in place I also
need to monitor the the health of the
actual microservices and understand the
dependencies one of the things that
you'll hear you know putting SOS or
service level objectives on a specific
service is very helpful and it gives you
some guideline and we can we'll talk
about this around you know what's the
best practice on doing that but also
understanding your service dependencies
and understanding what the critical user
journey is across your environment
becomes important you'll actually hear
people start talking about an SLO on the
critical customer journey through my
environment so you know and I'll give
you a very specific example if you're
just looking at this for a second if
front end goes down I actually have an
outage that's a big deal
if adds service goes down a
recommendation service goes down those
things you know do I wake up a person on
call for that maybe not so actually
really understanding the the dependency
map within your micro services becomes
very important to understand which one's
really impact your customer critical
journeys so service mash is really about
service master sto really empowers
developers and operators to focus on
their business and modernize and secure
their communications so this effectively
puts a lot of the info toil in looking
after the interconnect between micro
services and securing them into the
infrastructure so your your up your
service developers don't have to worry
about instrumenting you know
specific things within their code they
don't have to worry about creating you
know retries I have to worry about doing
circuit breaking this next actually
becomes part of the action
infrastructure itself you want to secure
those services you can start enabling
things like M TLS between your services
based on strong service identity so this
actually allows you to take control and
get a really good understanding of how
your services are connected one thing
Google is good at is they operate
distributed systems at scale there has
been a lot of effort around there's been
a book published around sre but also
just look at sort of you know the key
goal of an SRE organization is to
basically scale and scale the services
that you're running within your
environment but also make them resilient
reliable and provide a very good end
user experience so the question you know
you know how does that map to your
organization let's talk a little bit
about the three key pillars for sre the
three key pillars really mapped to SL
eyes which are service level indicators
we have SLO service level objectives and
SLA s I'm going to talk a little bit
briefly about all three of these and how
they're in have a different and also why
they're important so that one of the key
reasons so if you think of you know one
of the things that sto provides or
service mesh provides is they provide
consistent flow logs and metrics across
your entire environment these give you
what we would consider to be golden
signals these are things that you can
look at from an error rate perspective
for latency across your environment
these become the key metrics that you
use in order to construct your SLO zone
SOS tend to be targets that you would
map to business service level objectives
for your team you know so a given
development team would basically look at
what the objectives they wanted around
up time around latencies
for a specific service and you you tend
to do that over a rolling period of time
and we'll talk also a little bit about
arrow budgets as we move forward SLA is
though is a little bit different SOA it
tends to be more of a business agreement
that you map to your customer so let's
compare and contrast this ELO's versus
SLA is for a minute
so an SLO to me might be something that
I want to run on a a rolling period of
time over a week or a month but for an
SLA I actually want to map it to a
contractual obligation so for that might
be important here is so for if I have an
agreement for my customers that I'm
having a certain a certain amount of
availability for a given month I want to
make sure that I'm if my era budget he's
getting low for that month maybe I don't
roll out a version of code maybe I
actually hold back and wait so I'm
actually using the error budget for a
SLO to give me business indicators as to
whether or not I want to take the risk
to roll out something from a business
perspective and I think this is where so
we've sort of talked a little bit about
SLO s and s always I think this is
actually where service Mash can really
come in and help there is a lot of
things that you effectively get for free
from an infrastructure perspective when
looking at service Mash so that's sort
of touch base on so smash so the way
that we tend to talk about a service
mesh is it's effectively a way to
connect and secure services from a
network traffic perspective
automatically it gives you another key
thing with sto or service mesh is it
doesn't in a language independent way it
doesn't matter what version what you
know whether I'm actually writing up my
application in nodejs or go this
effectively just becomes again part of
the infrastructure
there are three main tenants to sto or
service mash the first main tenant is
around uniform observability the second
main tenant is around operational
agility and we'll talk a little bit
about how that actually helps and what
you can do with that and then the last
pet last tenant is really around policy
based security so let's take a little
bit of look a little bit of a look
around observability so one of the
things with the service masters you tend
to deploy a sidecar proxy co-located
with every service what that does it
gives you that nice consistent flow logs
and metrics across your entire
environment from that I get a very good
understanding
I get effectively metrics out of the box
I haven't had to instrument anything
within my application logic I can
basically just now deploy that sidecar
wherever that sidecar is I'm getting
those consistent flow logs and metrics
the other thing that we can do is we
based on that actual traffic flows we
can get an understanding of the topology
of the environment this isn't something
that is a theoretical diagram this is
now based on the actual traffic that is
flowing through your environment this is
important for a couple of reasons one is
because in some cases you know it's it's
sometimes even unclear as to exactly
what services are communicating with
other services this gives you a
representation of what's really
happening and it gives you the ability
potentially even to start locking down
your environment based on those
communication paths it's actually kind
of hard to see it's a little washed out
on that screen but there are lines
between all those circles the other key
thing is we can actually now construct
SOS in a consistent way across all the
services within that mesh and that's
actually something that Sundeep will
actually go through so let's talk a
little bit about how you get started so
there are a bunch of different ways you
can deploy osteo anyway from just going
to the open source repository using home
install it's actually relatively simple
to get started in doing so in
in kubernetes you would actually get
something sort of looks like this
there's a bunch of SEO components there
citadels effectively the CA components
you've got galley which does a configure
all the configuration pilot which pushes
all the information down of the sidecars
telemetry and policy I don't see
telemetry I'm probably covering it that
is effectively how you can do both
policy checks or integrate into backends
in a very flexible manner another key
thing that's important in the context of
gke is this sto sidecar injector what
that does is this allows you to turn on
on a per namespace basis if you choose
to do so where you want those sidecars
injected so this is a very easy way to
get that proxy deployed for every single
workload in that environment so what
does that actually look like so if i've
actually then deployed a given service
within a namespace it has the label
inject the sidecar when you actually
drill down into the container itself you
not only get the application that's
running but you also get that sidecar
just automatically inject it so it
becomes a very very simple to deploy
that these these are by the way all
these screenshots that I'm actually
showing the last couple have actually
been on gke but the previous ones are
all on an alpha project or an alpha
program that works you have available
too so if any was interested in trying
this stuff out please come see me
afterwards we're gonna and we're more
than happy to have a conversation and
then and once you've done that you can
effectively then start monitoring you're
actually good to go so this is
effectively what you know service
managing gets you from a you know going
through that process deploying your
service mash it gives you these
consistent things again very cleanly
out-of-the-box this diagrams a little
bit better because the actual lines are
showing up but I think this is kind of
like the the key that one of the key
things we're really focusing on here is
really embedding this capability within
the infrastructure itself to make it
easy for people to adopt this and start
monitoring
their services at the service layer so
at this point I'd actually like to
introduce Sundy to come up and about
setting up some best practices awesome
oh can we go back to the slides not
quite right for the demo yet thank you
so how do you take everything David just
talked about with sto and service mesh
and start applying some of those SR
reads best practices to your services so
remember you know what automation does
is Co give you out-of-the-box right like
it
by default it gives you this uniform
observability telemetry logs traces
metrics for all of your containers where
that sidecar proxy is injected it also
gives you this operational agility
component so things like managing
traffic rate limiting doing circuit
breakers injecting faults you can do all
that with with this do and it gives you
a single point of entry for implementing
policy and security across again either
your entire cluster your entire
namespace and that could be five
services it could be five hundred so it
gives you a lot of this automation to
really apply policy at scale across a
large number of infrastructure but let's
focus on observability here how do you
make practical use of the observability
in telemetry that SDO provides by
default and how do you use that in your
own work so let's recap again really
quickly SL eyes are the metrics that
you'll need to track SL those are the
targets that you want to achieve for
example you may say for a given service
right if you remember that complex
diagram earlier you may say you want the
cart service to have 99 percent
availability over the course of a week
or you may want the front end to have a
99 percent availability but maybe the ad
service could be 90 percent or 95
percent availability for a given week so
those are the kinds of targets that
you're gonna want to set the SLA SNR
finally the after you do enough of this
work what are the sorts of business and
end-user sort of guarantees can you make
about those services that you've been
strim nted so the first part of this
process is figuring out which SL eyes do
you care about right there's a whole
bunch that sto provides out of the box
which ones are the ones that are
important to you
and it's gonna be different on a service
by service basis right for some latency
may be very critical right for something
like the ad serving maybe for the
front-end latency is critical but maybe
fronting also needs availability some
others might just need availability
versus latency it's a little bit of a
trade-off but the ultimate idea is you
want to decide and I think a good look
at those services in depth and figure
out which metrics are the ones that are
most important for that particular
service again thinking about how that's
going to impact the end-user experience
or your other internal customer
experience right your internal customers
maybe other teams other services that
they're running other dependencies so
that's where you want to take into
account all of that information to
decide and determine which SL eyes are
important and then again back to SL O's
which ones are again the ones that are
most important for those workloads which
ones are the ones that are going to be
very obviously impacting anything
downstream or upstream from you so
that's an important piece and then
finally how do you use all that right
how do you put that all together well
the challenge with SLA is is that it's a
little bit subjective and it's not a
complete sort of mathematical operation
there's a little bit of work there you
can use to figure out well if I know my
SL is if I know the targets I'm trying
to achieve I can use that to figure out
what my error budget is I could say well
I can afford to have 60 minutes of
downtime in a given month or a given
year so you know what you're what you're
working with but from that point forward
what that final guarantee you have to
make is still a little bit subjective
right you have some data to back it up
but there's still a little bit of
determination to make before you can
make that guarantee or that promise to
internal external customers so what are
the SL is that you get out of the box
with service mention with this CEO so
you get six main things and you know
these things are dependent a little bit
upon what type of service you have
whether it's HTTP or TCP but regardless
of whether it's l4 l7 you get these
metrics again right on the box so that
includes things like request count the
duration of the request the size the
response size as well or like TCP bytes
sent and received and by the way there
are variations of these for both inbound
and outbound so you get to know this
from the perspective of
it's the source part of the workload or
a destination part of that workload you
have some ability to control which ones
again are most important to you the
important part of this is that your
applications don't have to emit these at
all
this is all done inside that sidecar
proxy so when you deploy your service
and that FCO sidecar that proxy is
injected along with it because it's
functioning at the network layer it's
automatically capturing all this
information and then sending it to those
telemetry backends and those telemetry
backends are then pushing it down to the
downstream monitoring services like
Prometheus Angra fauna like stackdriver
like data dog and there's a whole mix of
others so now that we know a little bit
about the SL is what does it mean to
start tracking health in more in in
depth right that's specifically around
the SL O's so you have to make a few
decisions as you're trying to create
these targets the first is what is the
type right what kind of what kind of SL
I might worried about and we give you
two options right out of the box inside
of the service management alpha which is
around latency or availability and then
on the SLO side on that specific
compliance piece you have to decide what
are the goals I'm trying to achieve 90%
95% 99% that's your compliance goal then
you have to design a window of time to
that or a period of time whether you
want it to be a calendar week or a
rolling week by week basis or a
day-by-day basis or even up to a year
and then finally you have the option of
setting a windowed SLI so that actually
adds a little bit of it's an optional
piece there but it adds a little bit
more specificity of I want to achieve a
particular metric compliance goal in a
smaller window of time and then it'll
aggregate those windows up to see if
you're reaching your compliance the
documentation does a little bit better
job of explaining it and with a few
examples but the idea being you have
different ways of kind of evaluating how
you want to track those slis and how you
want that to add up to your final
compliance goal so we look at a few
examples of this and these are somewhat
interchangeable so don't just go by the
rows i have those only those only pieces
there but
for example we could set a latency SLO
right where we want to hit 90 percent of
all requests are all responses are
within 100 milliseconds and we want that
to be over a rolling five-day period and
we also wanted to hit 99% of those in an
hour
right so what that really means is for a
given hour 99% of the requests have to
hit that 100 millisecond milestone and
then the aggregate that 90% kind of
rolls up from there on the next line we
have an availability example where we
want to hit again 99% availability
within a calendar week and we don't need
to window that one so we have a little
bit of room to figure out what's the
right combination here but really again
when you get back to that final piece
around SLA s you can't make that you
can't make those guarantees you can't
make those promises until you adopt sre
as a regular ongoing practice in your
organization so the first thing really
is not just deciding which SL eyes are
important but exploring them fully
making sure you have a really good
understanding of how those metrics are
functioning what that outcomes look like
what that output looks like and using
that in deciding which ones are the most
important right you can't really I mean
you effectively could monitor everything
but that might be missing sort of the
the you know the forest for the trees
you want to pick the ones that are most
important to you so you want to make
sure you have a really thorough
understanding after a lot of testing
around those SL eyes and then you want
to set realistic targets right go back
to that example earlier of you know not
every service needs the same level of
availability or maybe the same level of
latency guarantees you might have to
make trade-offs you might not have you
know a 5,000 person team to work with
here so you might have to decide and say
which one's am I going to guarantee are
99% available which one's might main
guarantee that I have a hundred
millisecond latency at 90% and if enough
exercise of this of those first two
right understanding those metrics in
depth and setting those targets after
you do enough of that work then you can
start to get to the next part where you
decide all right here's my error budget
for the year
here's how they can make that again that
final guarantee to my end-user or to an
internal customer so with service
management alpha what we tried to do
here is not just surface all the data
right that's I think that's sort of the
first easy part right giving you all
that data in and kind of easy to consume
dashboard that's great we did that we
did that first really important piece
but the next part of it is to give you
the tooling to kind of go a level deeper
and I don't mean sort of one level I
mean all the way through you know in our
first foray here is really round
observability but as time goes on you
can you could see that how that could
evolve to implementing more around even
just some of the agility or some of the
policy and security pieces as well but
we wanted to start with observability
because that's a really critical amount
of data and frankly what we hear from a
lot of people is their first real reason
for getting into sto getting into
service meshes because they want that
observability they want that level of
detail they can't get right now or they
want that level of detail that
individual teams have but they don't
have it in a uniform way across their
entire environment so from this
dashboard the first thing you'll see is
some important pieces across the top
here right services worth alerts firing
services that are out of our budget
and this was a default deployment I just
ran a couple of things here as an
example so it's not much happening to in
this example but it's a starting point
but then beneath that beneath that kind
of first level information we show you
all the services across clusters pods
namespaces that are running right there
and you have the ability to filter down
and dig into them
and this table is actually very active
where different lines can be read or
have different little checkmarks of
showing you which things are you know in
danger or running low on budget as you
dig into an individual service we'll
show you a timeline at the top and that
timeline actually shows you you know
right now it's it's blue because there's
no incidents but if there were incidents
or issues they're hard tick marks there
that you can dig into and you can narrow
that timeline say well I want to focus
on that one incident what happened
during that time and then you have the
ability to go through the individual
metrics or Diagnostics right the
Diagnostics include things like logs you
can look at the
specifically like which pods are
actually running the service and you
could see some of the inbound and
outbound traffic as well so you have the
ability to can dig in here a little bit
further and we surface a lot of the data
but we're trying to make it easy not
only to see all of it in action but also
take action on it very quickly so I
talked a little bit about this you know
what's interesting is that everything
you need to see and investigate is here
but in reality once you've spent enough
time understanding your SL is setting
realistic targets you really shouldn't
be spending a lot of time digging into a
services again and again if anything
once you've got really good s ellos
probably don't have to spend a lot of
time going back through the metrics
again and again because the important
thing that you need to know that you're
out of error budget or that you're
potentially hitting outside of your SLO
boundaries that's gonna be surfaced up
here as well right so you'll see some of
that stuff automatically so you
shouldn't spend too much time once
you've got everything up and running
having to reconfigure things again and
again so how do you again we talked
again we tried to take you from what is
tio provides you out-of-the-box
how you turn that into SLO s lis and
eventually SLA s well how do you do this
again in practice how do you get more
and more that specificity so let's start
with again that reasonably complex
workload this is sort of online commerce
app that we've got that we built and how
do we start to understand what's going
on there and let's pick a service maybe
that has some high tail latency and
first we'll examine all of them they
will pick something that we want to
drill into we'll dive deep into it and
create an SLO around it after we
evaluate some of those metrics so if we
could switch to the demo machine all
right so here I've got the service mesh
service management console up and can
you guys see that okay yeah all right
can't let me know just stand up and wave
hopefully I'll be able to see you so the
first thing we've got up here we've got
a bunch of services deployed and you can
see things across the top like where no
alerts are firing where we maybe have
alerts configured SLO that are
potentially out of error budget ones
that have no alerting policies or
services that have no SLO set so let's
look at some of those with no SLO set so
we'll filter by those and now we can see
let's and let's pick something here that
has like a high tail latency
I think checkout service there has a
high tail latency at 99% around 1700
milliseconds that's probably not we want
we want check out to be a much faster
operation so now we can dig into that
particular service alright now we can
see this through and we can also pull
down that timeline if we want to take a
quick look at it and that time span can
go from an hour up to six weeks
depending on how far back you need to
look but we'll leave it in an hour and
before we hit we get to creating an SLO
let's start taking a look at some of the
metrics and some of the Diagnostics that
we surface up for you right because
right now you'd be in that investigative
phase and you want to understand what's
happening so if we pull up the metrics
we can see here and I'm gonna hide this
timeline for now so we can see more of
it
we we break it down for you by request
per second by the error rate the latency
and the request and response sizes and
if we focus a little bit here on latency
we can see that generally speaking
latency is looking around you know let's
say 200 milliseconds roughly about 99
percent its 255 milliseconds but we do
have some some spikes here so we are
seeing things like two seconds right and
some in some cases but we can change
that break down into maybe by request
operation so we can see which particular
methods are driving some of that latency
so for example the checkout service has
a single method called place order and
so we could see that one and actually I
should mention this checkout service is
not a HTTP service it's actually a G RPC
service so this is servicing G RPC calls
just like they were HTTP methods so it's
easy to browse through them so we can go
through here and take a look around the
the latency piece if we look at the
request size
you know we can also change that break
down again by request operation or
request protocol we can even base it on
what is the source workload so in this
case all their incoming requests for
that service are driven by the front-end
only so that's a little bit of that one
and then the last piece I want to show
you is the error rate breakdown again
because we know the type here we know
it's G RPC or HTTP we can actually show
you the H to be error code that's coming
back out the other way so in this case
we've had zero errors which is good we
want to see a low error rate obviously
for our services now on the Diagnostics
tab what we'll show you there our error
logs and we show you the error log
breakdown by the types of messages that
you're seeing in your error logs these
logs aren't really that really anything
in particular just sort of default
things that we we put in there for this
example the more interesting piece gets
into things like infrastructure and
connected services when you expose the
infrastructure you have the ability then
to dig into all right you have a
deployment you have a service well
inside that deployment are multiple pods
now we can see each of those pods and
figure out which ones may be driving
some of those issues so we can see that
the high latency s are coming from these
two pods based on based on these two
rows in the table and we can also take a
look at the inbound and outbound traffic
as we can see all the inbound traffic is
being driven by front-end and all the
outbound traffic is going to other parts
of right so the cart service is making
outbound calls to curb sorry checkout to
making outbound calls to the shopping
cart currency service sending emails
after you place the order
maybe the payment service and I don't
want to undersell this when we've worked
with large customer teams where they've
had to take a large monolithic
infrastructure and turn into micro
services they've done that exercise but
what they haven't realized is how many
dependencies they've picked up along the
way
so when we were talking we were helping
a customer migrate from micro services
deployment on Prem to kubernetes we
actually had them stand up team by team
and tell us what their dependencies were
and as teams would stand up
ones they didn't even expect what
actually highlights a actually we're a
dependency on your service or you're a
dependency on our service and they
didn't even know about that so this
ability to kind of observe those inbound
and outbound connectivity is fantastic
for a lot of teams where they didn't
have this before because they're micro
service teams are very large but now
that we have some idea of what those
metrics look like let's actually go back
and go back to health and let's create
an SLO so we do that we're gonna first
pick a type as I mentioned earlier the
two that we surfaced by default our
availability and latency so we'll pick
latency because we know that's a that's
a problem for the checkout service and
we'll pick a low one here let's say we
want a one hundred millisecond like one
hundred millisecond latency we want that
to be the case ninety-five percent of
the time and we want to set this to be a
rolling seven-day period and so when you
pick all that if you look on the bottom
here will actually automatically name
those for you which does add a level of
convenience if you want to glance at
these very quickly so 95% of all
requests need to be less than 100
millisecond latency in a rolling period
of seven days and if we want we can
actually add the windowed version here
as well so we can add a window target so
we want to say that within those time
frames we want 90% of all windows right
there are five minutes long to meet that
and again it updates that name so now we
can say 90% of all five-minute windows
in a rolling seven days meet 95% latency
it's a little bit of a mouthful but it
does encapsulate exactly what we're
trying to track here I actually take
that one out and we'll go ahead and
create this SLO and you can see right
away we've got some status we're
actually out of air budget already with
that set up so the service level
indicator is telling us that we're only
hitting 5.9 percent of that target right
instead of 95 that we've actually burned
not only partway through our budget but
all the way through were actually
negative by about 5,000 minutes for the
time frame on our air budget and we're
only at five point nine percent
compliance right so this immediately is
bad situation and from here we actually
have the ability to create stackdriver
alerting policies so depending on which
SLO is again are the most critical as
part of your guarantee or your promise
to the end user you may want to create
alerting policies not every service
being out of error budget is it's sort
of equal but I think having that again
that notification to your team's and
saying and we need to address this
immediately that's an important part of
this whole process so if I were to hit
that it would open a new tab here and
that creates a tab instruct driver we're
not gonna wait for that to load right
now we'll come back to that one
and then why don't we do this while
we're here let's create another SLO
around availability right cuz that's
another important metric we're worried
about
so for availability for the checkout
service this is critical this is how we
get paid so we want ninety-eight percent
compliance here and we want that to be
across a calendar month so for every
month we want that to be the case so we
need to hit 99 percent availability in a
calendar month we'll create that one as
well
let me collapse this and you can see
actually this one got created above and
we are currently well within range we're
actually currently at a hundred percent
availability so above our target we've
still got our error budget remaining
ninety nine percent ultimately leaves
you with two hundred forty-four minutes
where you could be down so we're still
doing great on that one for the year
that's good now if we go back to the
main service management dashboard we'll
actually see this highlighted here
specifically where the checkout service
so that's readable is out of error
budget right there's an SLO side of
error budget and we can actually filter
by those as well up here at the top so
we can see now individual services that
are out of our budget so we can do the
same exercise here we can go explore
like that shopping cart service again
dig into this now this one actually is
great because we've actually got some
problems highlighted in that timeline
right you see some some red marks there
so we can actually narrow the window on
this timeline and let's let's pick this
incident here earlier today and roll
back
this one and now we can actually see
what some of the problem is you can dig
into the individual metrics during that
time frame see there was a sharp drop
here relatively speaking in in our quest
by scepter and crest per second maybe we
want to take a look at what the request
operation was that drove that so getting
the cart suddenly got dramatically
slower thinking we can scroll through
here we can see at the same time we saw
latency go up somewhat dramatically it's
scaled quite quite a bit up from there
right up to two seconds at the 99th
percentile in one case so this gives you
this ability again to zoom in and dig
around and again develop that
investigative understanding of those
services but really you probably
wouldn't be spending time doing this
once you've set those s ellos but in
order to set good ones you have to be
realistic you have to know the metrics
really really well alright so this it's
all it's all a process but it becomes as
you make it a regular practice as part
of deployment you get better at deciding
when to do you know as David mentioned
earlier when to do code pushes when you
do deployments well if you're out of air
budget for the month you may want to
hold off and wait till the next month
when you've got a little bit more room
to move around
and in that timeframe maybe you want to
investigate some of those metrics there
getting to figure out what's driving
this problem and one of the things we
didn't we mention what we didn't show
was tracing because that sidecar works
at the network level we automatically
get traces generated without instruments
in your code at all right so we did an
instrument for logs we didn't instrument
for metrics and we don't you have to
instrument for tracing but we can
actually trace inbound requests and a
pound request and figure out who's
taking up the most time in those
requests without anything without any
extra work that's something you get
right out of the box with service
mission this do
that's a quick tour of the service
management UI can we go back to the
slides please all right so how do you
get started with all this well the first
thing is if you're really interested in
digging in and testing out and trying
this UI right trying this new
functionality that takes that power of
SEO and kind of opens it up and exposes
all that data and some of those insights
out-of-the-box
come find Dave and I after the talk if
we get kicked out of the room we'll be
out in the hallway for a few minutes
come find us and we can talk to you
about it if you want to learn even more
and kind of dig in further around some
of those SEO core capabilities I would
definitely recommend check out this
welcome to the service mesh era series
that we wrote on the Google cloud blog
it goes through a bunch of conceptual
ideas around traffic management
telemetry with an SRE sort of focus
around how to roll security out using
SEO and there are actually companion
tutorials on github that go along with
it so you can actually try those
examples out today and then I would
definitely recommend you learn about SEO
telemetry and what again it provides out
of the box because it does give you
quite a bit now what I would tell you is
it gives you quite a bit on the box but
you can always add more right you have
the ability to add in your own custom
metrics that get captured by again
Prometheus Griffin or stackdriver
or whatever the other services that you
might want to use I would also ask for
your help in shaping this user
experience if you're interested if you
manage services on a regular basis if
you operate these deployments or these
platforms or these clusters for your
teams we want to hear from you we want
to build the best product we can to
again not just surface the data but give
you the insights that are critical to
really doing the best management job you
can of those services and of that
infrastructure so we definitely
recommend if you're interested not sure
where the music's coming from hope it's
not me that was weird
all right and then what's next for
service mesh well this was the first
session where we talked about service
management service mesh and there's a
whole host more and we recommend you go
to all these I would even say for some
of the 300 but ones if you're interested
it's still a good idea to learn that
level of depth and get into it there's
actually one right after this
and in about 40 minutes around taking a
deeper dive through SLO s and error
budgets and they talk about how
stackdriver helps you kind of get in
surface up that data and figure out how
you establish those error budgets and
where you can draw those lines around
which SL eyes are important and how you
make those into SL OHS and eventually
into SLA s and then tomorrow we've got a
full day of a ton of sessions we've got
some on Thursday as well so by all means
please join us and bring your questions
bring your stories we'd love to hear
from you before or after those talks
[Music]